In Afghanistan, the Taliban fired rockets toward the presidential palace in Kabul...
...while President Ashraf Ghani was giving a holiday speech...
...for the Muslim celebration of Eid al-Adha.
In Saudi Arabia, as the end of Hajj begins, so does the riskiest ritual:...
...muslim pilgrims throw stones at a wall symbolizing the devil.
Three years ago, a stampede at the ritual resulted in the deaths of hundreds.
In Britain, a man was charged with attempted murder...
...after assaulting a Polish mother and daughter...
...who claim they did not know who the man was.
In the US, a Nazi who worked at the Trawniki concentration camp...
...and then fled to the US after World War II...
...is being deported back to Germany at the age of 95.
Finally from Australia,...
...in Byron Bay, a diving instructor worked to remove plastic and netting...
...that had trapped a shark.
He stated that he couldn't let the animal die...
...especially because plastic kills millions of sea life each year.